[Music]
so uh as a kid i'm not very athletic and
i wasn't athletic as a kid it's not like
i just you know let myself go
i was never athletic but i did play
little league i played little league and
i was thinking about that today i was
the uh pudgy awkward kid
no it's okay i was a pudgy awkward kid
they have a place for him it's called
catcher
it's the catcher you don't have to run
sign me up so i just
put hot things on and kind of sat down
you know what i mean it's an awkward
thing being the catcher because you're
the only kid on the little league team
that has to wear a
a jock strap
and back in the 80s they didn't make
them in kids sizes you just had to get
the smallest adult size
which was gigantic
it's like getting a three-car garage to
protect my tricycle you know what i mean
i remember trying it on being like i
don't think this is gonna work
maybe i should get the top half of a
pistachio shell
[Applause]
and a rubber band
not the plastic cavern
walking around on the first day i got my
skin tight white baseball pants i got a
tortoise shell in here just trying to
play it cool yeah just a regular kid
regular kid
mario brothers too in my drawers
but i'm still not athletic actually one
of my biggest fears in my life is having
kids that are like super duper athletic
that is a terrifying idea children i'm
amazing children that i just can't keep
up with like imagine just like two
strapping chiseled square jawed
blonde-haired titans
who i just can't relate to and they're
mine and devin and dylan
or as they prefer to be called the
double d
and they're mine they live in my house
my self-esteem can't handle raising
athletes they're just like hey dad you
won't play catch yeah
but i can't
your perfect pitching rocket arms hurt
daddy's hand
seriously can you imagine me big fluffy
lumpy awkward me parenting two-strapping
tanned able-bodied jocks she's always
going around like hey pop
hey pop
in shape guys always call their dad pop
you know what i mean just to take him
down a peg hey pop i could kill you you
know what i mean just like that
already talking to me like i'm in a
point like i'm in a home like hey pop
show me which window you think is stuck
this one pop yeah
it's not a problem for me pop peanut
butter
showing off all their borderline
superhuman abilities around my wife
who's so impressed she's almost into
them
just some tiny woman that they hoist up
any time she needs to reach the flower
just like oh my big strong boys
love you mom
i'm sitting inside eating a sleeve of
chips ahoy the double deer in the
backyard effortlessly outrunning the dog
they wake up every morning with full
blonde god beards shave them off like a
man with a hot straight razor
meanwhile i'm borrowing my wife's lady
pink bic from the shower just to keep my
peach fuzz in line
devin runs into the kitchen and goes mom
hit me and that's their like little code
for her to toss a piece of raw carrot
into his mouth
that he catches perfectly between his
teeth like yeah two points mom
man i love healthy food
and he celebrates by doing push-ups she
sits on his back
makes me really uncomfortable but i'm
afraid to say anything so i just linger
in the pantry
just take a little more time than needed
in the pantry pretending i can't find
the triscus
but they're there
they're there
my kids start calling me slugger to
build up my confidence
but then just then that's how i imagine
it just as about uh devin is about to go
off to college on a baseball scholarship
he blows his knee perfect destroys his
athletic career forever he has to hole
up in bed eating cake and ice cream
reading comics and at that moment i go
now
now you're my son
[Applause]
[Music]